this is reminding me uh I don't know
when this airs but just days ago we lost
uh one of the great guitarists of all
time Jeff Beck passed away and I was
talking to a musician friend of mine and
he was saying did you ever meet Jeff
Beck and I thought I don't I don't think
Jeff Beck was on our show as a music
guest but I do remember one time where I
came out I used to warm up the crowd
myself in the early 90s I'd go out and I
would warm up the crowd and actually
like break a sweat warming up the crowd
myself not so cool because then I do the
monologue no one in America saw that
part I'd start the monologue and I
looked kind of sweaty and damp and
people thought he's a nervous wreck and
I'm like no no I just warmed up the
crowd but no one knew anyway I'm in the
crowd warming up the the crowd and there
was even a part where I used to sing
Elvis's Burning Love as like a joke and
people really like liked it because it
was so over the top and I'm doing it and
I finish and I'm like down on one knee
and Jeff Beck is sitting in the crowd
just to watch the talk show oh my God
and he had I think like stood in line or
maybe no way I don't know but he went to
see the show and so I'm freaking out the
whole show we get through it at the end
of the show I'm talking to him out in
the hallway and he's saying things like
must be great to have a talk show and I
said what anyway you know get to have
chats with all kinds of people and you
control and I was like you're Jeff Beck
yeah you're what we all want to be and
he'd be like and he was sort of
shrugging it aside like I know I play a
little guitar but
and then he's like to be able to have
different
entertainers and you chat with them and
then there's a commercial and then you
come back and then there's more of you
chatting and it's just a nice milieu
no I would love to hear him describe the
mcdlt
sesame seed bun and then he goes to the
McDonald's training facility where they
came up with it and they're like
your Chef back I mean you are original I
mean Yard Birds and the I mean you're
just the original good God it's you
Paige and Clapton that's it hold on
that may be so but
someone had the foresight to make the
Tomato crispy and Cold by putting it in
its own container you took two styrofoam
containers and put them together but
still each chamber has its own integrity
Preserve
the varying temperatures
you're right let's call it even
well I just want to make sure I get the
word out on shrinking yeah sure it's on
Apple TV plus yeah super cool 10
episodes of course uh and it's executive
produced by you and uh Ted lasso's
co-creator Bill Lawrence and star writer
Brett Goldstein and it drops on the 27th
I say drops that's cool because I'm out
there in the streets that's cool man
yeah yeah I know they're listening to
Kid and Play right now absolutely and
everybody's doing the cross everybody's
doing to crisscross they're all doing
the worm out there in the playground and
um shabadu shrimp is coming by in half
an hour oh no you didn't
wow well you know it's so funny this is
called uh Conan O'Brien he's a friend
and and this is one of those moments
where I'm thinking why aren't we friends
right I'm sure but seriously like I I
know the area you live in I could come
over there I would love that that's a
weird way
yeah I know your gate code yes yeah
come on well is that a weird thing so
close and then you say I know the area
you live
I could come over there and I did that a
lot I said that a lot in my 20s long
before I was even interviewed interview
yeah it didn't go well I went great I
thought it went great don't let them
bully you thank you I'll show them you
know what when I say Jason when I say
I'll show them it's these two
right here yeah I'll show them